your hands help tell your life story
from the calluses of an expert bass
player to the healed burns of a seasoned
chef hands can also help unveil the
lives of those far before our time our
cousins the Neanderthals who went
extinct over 40,000 years ago over the
past decades we've seen increasing
complexity in the remnants of
Neanderthal lifestyle such as small
stone tools although it was clear from
their Anatomy that Neanderthal hands
could form a precise pincer like grip to
make tools interpretations of their
fossils have suggest that they usually
used a different more power oriented
grip new methods to analyze ancient
bones have reconciled our cultural
understanding of Neanderthal behavior
with their fossilized remains the
impressive leg muscles of an avid
cyclist or massive forearms on a drummer
aren't preserved in fossils but the
attachments of these hard working
muscles leave scars behind marks that
can tell us about the work they did
typically the greater the size of these
marks called n thesese the stronger the
muscle attached to the bone a previous
study of 19th century human bones found
a close relationship between life
occupation and n thesese tailors or
painters those that perform delicate
precise tasks displayed a pattern of
entha sees different from bricklayers or
carpenters that engaged in more intense
manual labour these patterns reflect two
categories of hand grips precision grips
and power grip in precision grips the
thumb and index fingers do the heavy
lifting while power grips rely more on
the thumb and pinky researchers used a
3d scanner to image early modern humans
and Neanderthals fossils then determine
their hand grip through rigorous
statistical analysis
all the Neanderthal fossils were in the
precision grip category which supports
archaeological evidence of Neanderthals
fashioning small stone tools a power
grip would have been too strong to
create some of these delicately flake
tools in contrast half the early modern
human samples from around 40,000 years
ago displayed precision gripping while
the other half displayed power gripping
in the future these methods can be used
to provide insight about the hand grip
of other early humans as well as how
these ancestors used other muscles what
answers do your hands hold
[Music]